[Applause]
a protest that's been days in the making
thousands of people gather on the
streets of hartoum demanding a return to
transitional government something they
say was robbed from them after the
military coup on monday
we went to the street because we reject
the military rule and we reject
authoritarianism and we categorically
reject all the behavior of the military
council
we want to topple the security committee
and bring it down we don't trust these
people this is not their first coup we
need the world to know that the sudanese
people are living under oppression and
are being beaten our voices are not
listened to because there is no coverage
and there is no internet
they're risking a lot
days of protests in the capital led to
street to street battles with the
military and demonstrators killed with
the internet cut off organizers used
masks flyers and graffiti to reach
people
the military also blocked the main road
to the airport the planned route of this
march saturday's protests were met with
tear gas and live ammunition what is
really concerning is the vast you know
array of military and security actors
that are on the streets there are just
incredible set of of of security sectors
that now patrol the streets um
no sense that they are necessarily
taking orders from a central spot and i
think that um you know that diversity of
different military actors is really the
worry
these demonstrators are demanding that
prime minister abdullah's cabinet be
restored it was toppled by general abdel
fattah al-burhan
he also dissolved the sovereignty
council established after the overthrow
of umar al-bashir two years ago some
political parties have supported the
coup
burhan says he will hold elections in
july 2023 and then hand power to the
elected civilian government
but the takeover has provoked
international condemnation the un and
u.s has called on the military not to
intervene in the protests
regional and international actors have
been urging general burhan to reverse
his school and restore the transitional
government which he dissolved on monday
but many protesters here say even if
that happens it still falls short of
their demands to completely hand over
power to civilian rules
the people on khartoum streets call it a
power grab and demand a return to a
democratic process heber morgan
al-jazeera horton